[Music]
foreign
look at what's on the front pages as
they arrive in the next half hour we'll
see what's making the headlines with
Kevin Schofield political editor at the
health post UK and Noah Hoffman
political reporter for the Sun so let's
see what's on some of those front pages
for you now well the Metro leads with
the row between the BBC and Gary lineker
with the headline linica muzzled for now
BBC executives are scrambling to repair
relations with the former England
Captain according to the guardian to
prevent a staff Mutiny at the
corporation
the telegraph says the BBC will climb
down and allow Gary lineker to return as
much of the day host next Saturday
that's also in the mail their headline
will BBC do lineker deal today to end tv
standoff
and the times BBC bosses seek truce to
get lineker back on side
and the star is warning a new polar
blast could bring a white Easter the
paper says it's time to ask the east
bunny the Easter Bunny for a chalk ice
okay
[Laughter]
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
Kevin Schofield the political editor at
healthpost UK and Noah Hoffman political
reporter at the sun welcome to you both
let's start with the Daily Mail and
their headline will BBC do linica deal
today to end the TV standoff this comes
off the back of those close to him
saying that the matter is likely to be
resolved to Gary lineker's um uh to his
liking shall we say on Monday what do
you think Evan
yeah all the indications seem to be that
um they are going to have to climb down
the BBC that's seemed to be on the cards
ever since all the sports coverage over
the weekends will be completely thrown
into chaos by
um BBC colleagues of garileneca refusing
to to take part um after he was pulled
from match the day late on Friday
um it's a pretty big accumulation really
for the BBC it's hard to imagine how
this could have gone any worse for them
we had the ridiculous
um scene last night of match of the day
been only on for 20 minutes no theme
music uh no commentators no pundits no
presenter it was just far Circle really
and something had to be done and we all
wait really to find out exactly what
Geralyn because deal is with the BBC how
they've managed to compromise on this
situation but uh but yeah it's um it's
been a fairly humiliating experience
it's for the BBC being badly handled by
them from the very beginning and get
along the looks as those come out on top
I think it's proving that um that they
need him certainly more than he needs
them uh no the male is saying that a BBC
spokesman is quoted
um saying we are working hard on a
resolution hope to have him back with us
as soon as possible so it looks as if we
are coming to the the end of this story
do you think
I hope so I mean I think nobody is
enjoying this
um it shouldn't really have happened in
the first place Gary has previously
tweeted political opinions
um and so that should have been
something the BBC had thought about and
clarified with him as to which direction
he should go whether he should quiet in
town or whether he has free reign to
speak his mind a while ago I think
there's sort of two kind of solutions to
this
um issue which really boils down to
um the social media policy for BBC staff
and and Freelancers just not being clear
or consistent enough uh when it comes to
non-news and current affairs roles
either they should sort of have a
blanket policy where any presenter in
arts in sport and entertainment
um has there's a blanket policy no
political opinions on social media
whatsoever or they say you can give
political uh opinions if you're not in
using current it says but then that
policy has to apply consistently whether
that's to Lord Alan sugar who also
um tweets political opinions as well as
Gary lineker so it just really boils
down to being consistent and clear and
hopefully that's what tomorrow will
achieve the Metro headlines suggesting
that Gary lineker has been muzzled but
only for now and that's the the issue
isn't it Kevin whether he is going to be
allowed to continue
um putting his thoughts on Twitter or
perhaps will there be a rewriting of the
BBC guidelines on impartiality
yeah and I think I think Noah's right
that does have to be greater Clarity I
think there's an awful lot of gray areas
around the BBC social media usage policy
I mean obviously this isn't the first
time that Gary lineker has tweeted
political opinions he's very vocal on
brexit for instance and no one is in any
doubt where he really stands on that
particular debate so um yeah he has up
until now always just tweeted his mind I
saw an interview from a couple of years
ago with him that um was shown again on
on Twitter uh a couple of days ago which
it shows he's very he's very thoughtful
I think about what he tweets he doesn't
tweet when he's been drinking he says he
doesn't tweet when he's angry and he
thinks about everything that he tweets
and if he's in any doubt at all he
doesn't hit send so
um you know he does think these things
through and it'll be interesting to see
whether or not he has agreed to some
sort of
um toning down of his presence on social
media but I'd be very surprised if he
was willing to accept that and as I said
earlier you know he doesn't need the
BBC's as much as as they need him you
know you could very much very well get
work as a broadcaster elsewhere so um
and maybe I'll be that he's had to agree
to some sort of
um a compromise of his social media
usage but as I said I think that's the
BBC are the ones who are in the weak
position here they're desperate to get
him back on the TV desperate to get Alan
Shearer Ian Wright Alex Scott all the
people who have refused to work we'll
get a little Nick has been suspended
they want them back as quickly as
possible as well and to put this
um whole mess behind them
I know it does from from what we've seen
thus far seem as if it will be that the
BBC that that climbs down because we
know that Gary lineker
um refused to apologize for the the
Tweet um and seemingly He he'll want to
continue his presence on on Twitter
um and sharing his views with with the
public
yeah he's made that very clear and it
does seem to be heading in that
direction where the BBC will be that
perhaps the ones to step back and say
okay we've gone too far
um or I mean we just don't know yet but
if that is the case if it is the BBC who
takes that step back you can expect a
lot of Anger from Tory MPS from the Tory
back benches obviously not everyone but
The View among a lot of the Tory party
is that anyone who's receiving taxpayer
funds whether that's you know an a
million plus salary as Gary has or
anyone else if you're in receipt of
taxpayer money you should not be
expressing a political opinion so I
don't think Tory Buck benches will take
it lightly if it is the BBC uh to step
down in this case Kevin that's that's an
interesting point what do you think
about all of those um conservative MPS
who were calling for some action to be
taken against Gary lineker
oh yeah I mean there was a few of them
um
sort of strangely saying that they
preferred match the day last night
without Geralyn and Corona I'm not sure
that's true actually I think it was a
lot but performative but uh but yeah I
think Noah's absolutely bang on there I
think there will be
um conservative MPS will be very angry
that the BBC
um as a partner going to climb down and
like Carolina back on the TV and they
don't agree with his politics and they
don't like to see him tweeting about it
and while he's employed by the BBC so
yeah I'm sure there will be a bit of a
political backlash so I mean the BBC
they've had they've had to wait what's
worse getting a bit of a kicking from a
few Tory MPS or not being able to have
much of the day back on as normal next
Saturday night I think that's a bit of a
about an easy choice to make really yeah
let's move away from uh Gary lineker in
the BBC to the Daily Telegraph and this
story about where she's doing like
announcing five billion pounds an
increase in military spending to uh
quote fortify our national defenses um
this has been perhaps a long time coming
and something that we've certainly heard
those senior in the military uh calling
for Noah
yeah that's right so tomorrow we will
have the publication of the integrated
review refresh uh which will sort of set
out what um what position the UK is in
terms of
um how uh well-resourced the military is
what threats the UK currently face it is
currently facing and what sort of short
medium and long-term future planning
needs to take place and funds needs to
be given to the ministry of Defense in
order to secure our national security to
secure our borders so the mod has said
they will be giving an extra 5 billion
pounds to the minister uh the government
will be giving a Ministry of Defense an
extra five billion pounds now the
defense secretary Ben Wallace has
previously stated he wants 11 billion
pounds he has said he's delighted with
this latest round of funding but I think
Rishi soon at tomorrow will have to
really explain to reporters as he's in
San Diego
um to talk about the military to talk
about the ukraining War why 5 billion is
enough why he isn't going that extra
length and I know he'll say you know we
don't have unlimited money but why he
isn't taking that extra step to give the
11 billion that uh Ben Wallace has asked
for in the past are we safe enough with
just that 5 billion will that be enough
to replenish the military which is
really running low on resources because
of the war in Ukraine and rightly so
we've been helping out providing
um equipment there but that needs to be
replenished we're in a very insecure
landscape with the rise of China again
with Peterson's Antics as well so he'll
have a lot of explaining to do as to why
that
um that figure and Kevin we read that
the Prime Minister will also pledge to
boost military funding to 2.5 percent of
GDP
um that's significantly less though than
the three percent uh raise promised by
Liz Truss
yeah I mean that was another one let's
trust these big promises
um along with all the tax cuts that she
was going to introduce and we know how
that how that turned out it was never
actually fleshed out exactly where that
money would come from at the moment we
spend running about two percent so going
up to 2.5
in due course I noticed that doesn't
even have a a deadline on it either but
that's a an ambition and I think that's
probably a more realistic one than the
three percent that let's trust demanding
but again that could potentially be
storing up a little bit of trouble for a
British tonight because let's trust as
we know hasn't gone away you know she's
quite Keen to think to be vocal on
issues which are close to our heart and
one of them is certainly defense
spending so it'll be interesting to see
if she decides to see anything
um about this but yeah and also the
interesting I think to see what Ben
Wallace did the defense secretary
whether or not he bides his time for now
at this 5 billion rather than 11 billion
that he was looking for and maybe maybe
keeps his powder dry if you upon for the
next spending round maybe not for this
budget but this time next year okay
let's uh stay with the politics of A
Sort um this is the prime minister
um
well his basically the power grid has
had to be upgraded to facilitate his uh
new heated private pool
Noah
yes so interesting story in the guardian
um the story does make very clear that
the upgrades needed um to the power grid
to facilitate his heated swimming pool
were all um paid for by him no taxpayers
money went into this um and similarly
the article makes very clear that the
Prime Minister did not use his position
to receive any sort of preferential
treatment to facilitate the warming of
his swimming pool but you know in
politics a lot of things come down to
Optics so you know when people are
struggling with energy bills when
um you know people are choosing between
heating their home and feeding their
families
um I don't know this perhaps might not
be the best look and I think a lot of it
boils back down to that age-old question
of is is Rishi sunak too rich to be
prime minister
um I mean I think her the in Britain we
don't punish people um for being
aspirational for wanting to build wealth
and having the freedom to choose how
they spend it but the important detail I
think in this story is that it wasn't
taxpayers money that funded this upgrade
if it was that would be a scandal and
rightly there would be a lot of outrage
no absolutely this is obviously
privately funded but um the the Optics
as Noah was saying Kevin don't look
great when people can't Heat their homes
and the prime minister is heating his
pool
oh yeah I mean it's a pretty remarkable
story I think um I think it'll find its
way onto a few labor election leaflets I
think as we approach the next general
election the idea that in the middle of
a cost a living crisis and with people
who struggling to pay their energy bills
the prime minister is um haven't
installed basically taken extra
electricity to heat his massive private
swimming pool I mean I do take on board
you know he is paying for himself as as
he should but I just think it looks bad
at a time when the government is very
keen to to show that they are to
um convince people that they are in
touch with the ordinary man in the
street there aren't very many men or
women in Industry I think you have to
worry about um heating their own private
swimming pool Kevin and Noah for the
moment thank you do stay with us but
coming up on the front page of the times
the treasury scrambles to protect Tech
firms after Bank collapse well on that
when we come back
[Music]
foreign
welcome back you are watching The Press
preview still with me political
journalist Kevin Schofield and Noah
Hoffman welcome to you again let's have
a look at
um the Telegraph and this story on the
front page government allays fears of
financial
crisis I wish you soon I can Jeremy Hunt
try to ease spares of a new financial
crisis last night after British startups
were left on the brink from the First
Bank collapse since
2008. it takes into this story Kevin
yeah so this is to do with this uh
Silicon Valley Bank in America which has
collapsed now uh the government here is
very eager to insist that uh there's
gonna be very little contingent very
little knock-on effect in this country
and that they're all over it and the
bank of England is in control and the
treasury is keeping a very close eye on
it and things that are going to be fine
but if you read the story in the Thames
you know there's still something like 3
000 uh British tech companies have
deposits of around 7 billion pounds in a
UK subsidiary off the bank so that's
obviously a lot of money there's
concerns that these um companies won't
be able to meet payroll uh pay the bills
as well and they are going to need some
form of bailout to fit effectively from
the government and to help them through
this crisis until
um The Hope anyway that the the
subsidiary in the UK is maybe bought out
by another bank to get things back on
even kill but yeah obviously it brings
back
um horrible memories of 2008 and the
knock-on effects of lehmann's
um and what happened over the other side
of the Atlantic it also came over here
and caused the financial crash in the UK
as well so
um tomorrow morning things can be very
interesting we'll see how the Stock
Market opens
um I'm sure Jeremy Hunt will be keeping
an eye on that it's not it's not the
greatest build up for him ahead of
Wednesday's budgets but um they'll be
keeping their fingers crossed to any and
as I say contagion in this country it's
kept an absolute minimum and because he
certainly don't want to repeat of what
happened there back in back in 2008 yeah
no it's perhaps not a bank that many
have heard of Silicon Valley Bank but
apparently it's it's um home to schools
of UK based uh in the tech business
yeah and I think that's significant
because over not just the past few weeks
but sort of the past few months um even
from when Rishi sunak became prime
minister he's really been championing
the idea of UK being you know a startup
Nation a place where investors want to
go to you know invest in the next
unicorn where all the best brains in
Tech and app development in that whole
field uh come so to have this affect the
UK is not ideal for them again as
um Kevin said ahead of the budget as
well but Jeremy Hunt and treasury
sources have been really clear that they
have been working non-stop to put
together a package uh that will resolve
the situation we also know as Kevin said
that um some bids have been submitted
formally to the treasury and we should
find out more tomorrow Labor is
demanding
um
comprehensive package by tomorrow
morning as well but I think it you know
even though it doesn't affect a lot of
people a lot of your everyday men and
women on the street when you've got
ministers going um to Davos going doing
these um treasury connect public q a
sessions with Business Leaders saying uh
the UK is the world's next AI superpower
this is the key to growth this is how
we're gonna
um uh reverse a really awful situation
with public finances it's really
important they get this right